para aprender idiomas tenemos que
dominar lo básico es verdad no noticias
de última hora no es posible dominar lo
básico sobre todo al inicio Vamos a
continuar a cometer los mismos errores
durante largo tiempo Entonces tenemos
que no preocuparse de esta inútil
voluntad de dominar lo básico Qué es lo
básico y yo lo digo de mi experiencia
como aprendiente de idiomas no Qué es lo
básico las palabras por ejemplo palabras
básicas Qué son las palabras básicas ha
muchos libros que enseñan idiomas
empiecen con yo no sé los colores los
números pero esas cosas son muy
difíciles hay palabras con más
frecuencia pero de todas maneras estas
palabras vamos a encontrarlas con alta
frecuencia Entonces vamos aprender esas
palabras más fácilmente pero ciertas
palabras van a seguir ser difíciles a
acordarse de esas palabras no Y la misma
cosa por eh estructuras para mí para
ejemplo ahora estoy hablando en español
que no hago mucho entonces voy cometer
errores básicos pero si hablo más pues
cometería menos errores básicos no
Entonces lo básico es un concepto muy
subjetivo y de todas maneras hay un
orden natural de adquisición de un
idioma según estudias que han hecho por
ejemplo Steven crashen y este orden
natural de adquisición puede depender
del idioma que estamos aprendiendo de
nuestro idioma a nosotros por ejemplo un
italiano que está aprendiendo español
Pues será más fácil Eh muchas cosas de
la gramática y también las palabras son
parecidas a palabras o estructuras en
italiano entonces hay un orden natural
que es diferente Pero por alguien que
está aprendiendo por ejemplo inglés eh
sabemos todos que en el inglés la
tercera persona del presente tiene un es
por ejemplo I go you go he goes pero
este es muy difícil es una cosa
gramatical básica pero los Non nativos
continúan a cometer este error muy
simple porque tenemos que construir
hábitos nuevos y este se hace según un
orden Natural y se hace a lo largo no
entonces
deliberadamente tratar de aprender
dominar lo básico es inútil y no ayuda
porque todo el tiempo que estamos
tratando aprender por ejemplo las
conjugaciones es tiempo que yo no voy a
utilizar para escuchar más leer más
hablar más para qué mi cerebro se
acostumbre al nuevo idioma y por esa
razón que en link Por ejemplo yo siempre
Empiezo con las minihistorias que son
fáciles con mucha repetición y de esta
manera se crea un una idea del idioma
porque finalmente podemos focar noos en
lo básico después que tengamos una idea
del idioma y podemos al fin después de
eh mucha experiencia con el idioma
tratar de perfeccionar por no decir
dominar porque vamos a continuar a
cometer errores es muy importante no
tener un sentimiento de frustración Y si
después de mucho tiempo estamos
cometiendo errores básicos porque este
es el caso es el caso mío eh creo que es
el caso por la mayoría de la gente que
aprenden idiomas entonces más importante
es mantenerse activo seguir escuchando
leyendo gozando del idioma y poco a poco
se va a mejorar y si después quieres
concentrarte en ciertos aspectos de
vocabulario o de gramática puedes
hacerlo y sería más fácil asimilar esas
cosas explicaciones patrones porque
finalmente el fundamento del idioma no
es como construir una casa con ladrillos
no es no como hay un fundamento y
después vamos a construir el segundo
piso tercer piso no es como un plato de
gelatina las cosas entran y salen
aprendemos y olvidamos y es por esa
razón que en link no medimos El Progreso
de los estudiantes no porque este es
difícil algunas veces tenemos la
impresión de progresar y después no pero
lo que podemos medir eh Y lo más
importante es el nivel de actividad de
cada cada uno si el aprendiente sigue
activo escuchando leyendo con el tiempo
pasando con el idioma con un actitud
positiva es seguro que va a progresar
Entonces mi consejo como una persona que
yo he aprendido a diferentes niveles
muchos idiomas es que las cosas básicas
no podemos dominarlos hay que continuar
a estudiar cocer leer cosas interesantes
y poco a poco vamos a a acostumbrarnos
al nuevo idioma sin molestarnos con esta
voluntad de dominar lo básico hasta
luego